[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos de visual política el
mundo ha cambiado y no no me estoy
refiriendo al coronavirus en este vídeo
os vamos a hablar de la revolución que
ha vivido el sector energético durante
la última década más en concreto del
auge espectacular que ha tenido el gas
natural licuado
el cnl y también de como la revolución
del fracking ha cambiado esos
equilibrios de poder que siempre están
detrás del comercio de los recursos
energéticos
[Música]
efe
el agua
las podemos
el fracking ha provocado que eeuu haya
disparado su producción de gas natural
de tal manera que desde el año 2017 el
país del tío sam es plenamente
autosuficiente para satisfacer su propio
consumo
[Música]
de hecho es que pasta les sobra tanto
como para plantearse exportarlo claro
que por su situación geográfica la
cuestión es a quién porque eeuu
continental tiene tan solo dos vecinos
al norte canadá un país que también es
autosuficiente en gas y que de hecho
desde hace décadas lo exporta en grandes
cantidades a la costa oeste de los eeuu
luego al sur está méxico que ya recibe
por gasoducto desde eeuu más de la mitad
de todo el gas que consume pero es que
aún así no es suficiente porque lo
cierto es que a eeuu sigue sobrando
mucho pero que mucho más y amigos para
mirar a otros continentes necesita
recurrir al g ml
el gas natural tradicionalmente se
exporta a través de los gasoductos pero
hay un obstáculo para esta forma de
transportar el gas los océanos los
gasoductos submarinos existen pero
establecer una tubería bajo el agua
durante miles de kilómetros de una gran
profundidad es algo terriblemente caro y
técnicamente muy complicado así que para
el comercio entre países muy alejados
queda una única alternativa el gas
natural licuado
siempre y llanamente el gene l tiene una
enorme ventaja respecto a los
gaseoductos llega a mercados a los que
resulta imposible llegar mediante una
tubería el caso de eeuu es muy claro es
el mejor ejemplo de cómo han cambiado
los mercados mundiales del gas durante
la última década
pero no es un caso aislado incluso
países con una gran tradición como
exportadores de gas también se están
apuntando a esta nueva moda del gn él es
la estrategia de gas de rusia prioriza
el gene l con un papel más modesto para
gazprom eeuu y rusia pero también
australia qatar
nigeria el mundo está apostando muy
fuerte por el cnl echando un vistazo a
este gráfico sobre la nueva capacidad de
licuefacción el azul que representa al
mundo destaca más en los últimos años y
el rojo que representa a eeuu
fijaos
[Música]
y por supuesto si hablamos de gas
hablamos también de dinero mirad lo que
dice fatih birol director de la agencia
internacional de la energía
las inversiones en genere alcanzaron un
récord de 50 mil millones de dólares en
2019 ya lo veis 50 mil millones en sólo
un año el mercado mundial del gn le está
moviendo por las diferentes capitales
del mundo más billetes que los atracos
de la casa de papel así que la pregunta
que podemos hacernos es por qué este
creciente interés por el gn l en el
mercado energético global qué cambios
puede provocar en las relaciones
internacionales de las principales
potencias digamos que hay un misal
político nos toca hacer del profesor y
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
en vez
la tecnología para licuar el gas natural
no se desarrolló hasta la década de los
60 pero la revolución que el gene le ha
traído a los mercados ha llegado en la
última década en 10 años se ha
multiplicado por 2 el volumen de nl
comercializado en todo el mundo una
tendencia que se ha acelerado a partir
de 2016 cuando australia rusia y sobre
todo eeuu han apostado por inundar de nl
el mercado energético mundial y es que
veréis el fracking ha provocado que eeuu
haya aumentado su producción de gas
natural en un 80 por ciento desde el
2005 es decir produce en la actualidad
casi el doble de gas que hace apenas 15
años algo que explica que eeuu no sólo
haya conseguido desde el año 2017
satisfacer su propio consumo sino que le
sobra tanto gas como para plantearse su
exportación
la revolución del fracking cambió por
completo los planes de las empresas
energéticas de eeuu infraestructuras que
se habían diseñado para importar enormes
cantidades de gas recibieron una
inversión de 100 mil millones de dólares
para transformarse en instalaciones
dedicadas a la exportación casi de
repente el objetivo pasó a ser licuar el
gas natural es decir convertirlo en
estado líquido enfriando lo hasta llegar
a 162 grados centígrados bajo cero y
exportarlo mediante buques metaneros
[Música]
por supuesto cuando tienes una mercancía
dispuesta ya para la venta sólo falta
una cosa el comprador y quiero ha sido
el comercial agresivo que se ha
encargado de colocar el cnl
estadounidense en el mercado pues ni más
ni menos que el presidente donald trump
sus tácticas ya las conoceis primero
amenaza con imponer aranceles a diestro
y siniestro y luego pues negocia en 2018
amenazó con abrir una guerra comercial
transatlántica con la unión europea que
fue lo que consiguió pues mirar lo que
prometió el entonces presidente de la
comisión europea jean claude juncker a
cambio de que eeuu no impusiera
aranceles a los coches europeos
we fight to string conversion anoche you
will be water mails en público y el gas
y como solemos decir por aquí en visual
político dicho y hecho el gas
estadounidense pasó de representar un
raquítico 5% de todo el gml importado en
2018 a alcanzar una cuota del 15 por
ciento un año más tarde en 2019 las
estadísticas no engañan
[Música]
tiene esas estábamos cuando llegó el
coronavirus porque todo se ha juntado en
2020 por un lado encontramos que europa
tiene sus almacenes de gas a un nivel de
ocupación del 60 por ciento frente al 40
que suele ser lo habitual si a eso le
sumamos el parón productivo que han
sufrido las economías a causa del
'hobbit' 19 que es lo que nos
encontramos pues un mercado que ha
tenido que decir basta no necesito más
gene l por ahora y esto esto es un
problema es un problema porque ya sabéis
que el presidente donald trump trata a
sus aliados y en función de sus
intereses comerciales que me compras
eres mi mejor amigo como que no me vas a
comprar te vas a enterar y la verdad no
creo que le guste ver como europa está
cancelando pedido del general
estadounidense aunque sea simplemente
porque su demanda no da para más
[Música]
bueno es que incluso en los peores
momentos de la crisis de el coronavirus
se llegó a producir un atasco de
metaneros de barcos metaneros en las
costas europeas buscando una
regasificadora donde poder descargar los
buques metaneros degeneres se acumulan
alrededor de la europa afectada por el
virus a medida que la crisis disminuye
en asia en cualquier caso a pesar de los
buenos datos de venta a europa en 2019
no hay que perder la vista que el país
al que eeuu se exporta más gn l no es
otro que corea del sur
[Música]
hablamos del tercer país que más gente
le importa de todo el planeta el apetito
de cuerda del sur por el gas no para de
crecer y eso eso seguro que sí que le
gustará donald trump porque amigos en
los próximos años
eeuu competirá de tú a tú con las
grandes potencias exportadoras como
qatar y australia la cuota del gen el
estadounidense en el mercado surcoreano
sin duplicar después de cerrar este
acuerdo con bp a través de este contrato
a largo plazo se espera que las
importaciones aumenten a 7,9 millones de
toneladas para 2025 lo que supondrá un
22,8 por ciento de nuestras
importaciones y esperamos ver la
expansión del comercio de energía entre
nuestros países la diversificación de la
adopción del gas natural y la
estabilidad del suministro de gas
natural ministerio de industria de corea
del sur y hay amigos que pasan en
noviembre en noviembre de este año si
elecciones hay elecciones en eeuu y
nadie se atreve decir quién se sentará
finalmente en el despacho oval
[Aplausos]
lo que sí es seguro pero vamos seguro
seguro seguro es que una vez superado
este bache de el coronavirus que estamos
pasando el gml estadounidense seguirá su
auge exportador por todo el mundo vamos
hasta seguros estamos de ello como que
trampas hay utilizando el eje nl en su
peculiar forma de hacer política el
tiempo que le queda en la casa blanca
grandes noticias como prometió hace dos
semanas el primer envío de gn le acaba
de salir de la planta de exportación de
gen l de cameron en luisiana no sólo se
han creado miles de trabajos en eeuu
estamos enviando libertad y
oportunidades al extranjero
donald trump libertad y oportunidades
más allá de sus fronteras pero de qué
demonios está hablando tram por si amigo
si habéis escuchado bien si en este
episodio y alguien rehén estamos
precisamente hablando del gas ruso que
mantiene cautiva a europa desde hace ya
décadas y la pregunta es dejar a
vladimir putin que el gn el
estadounidense llegue tranquilamente a
las costas del viejo continente europeo
bendice tiras hemos contado que tienen
una estrategia así que donde se libran
las batallas en europa pues donde
siempre atentos
berlín siempre berlín
[Música]
el bloque de países formado por la unión
europea es el tercer mayor consumidor de
gas natural tras eeuu y rusia
claro a diferencia de lo que pasa en
estos dos países la producción gasista
del bloque comunitario lleva años en
declive
hoy por hoy apenas satisface un 15% del
consumo total de europa así que
evidentemente eso supone que tenemos que
traer el gas de terceros países ahora
bien dentro de los 27 socios alemania es
con mucha diferencia el que tiene una
mayor demanda acapara ni más ni menos
que el 24 por ciento de todas las
importaciones europeas de gas y como lo
hace alemania pues básicamente un cien
por cien le llega por gasoducto 10 por
ciento por buque metanero y claro es que
cuando angela merkel le llega a la mitad
del gas desde rusia pues que luego nadie
se sorprenda que si putin invade crimea
en berlín nadie mueva un dedo
y lo peor es que esta dependencia del
gas ruso irá cada vez a más ya que
alemania ha anunciado a la energía
nuclear a partir de 2023
así que alemania necesita sí o sí
diversificar sus fuentes de energía si
no quiere quedar sometido casi por
completo a los deseos de moscú y es que
las advertencias de berlín no han parado
de producirse mirad la última alemania
necesita más gene l para complementar
las energías renovables según la agencia
internacional de la energía la unión
europea alcanzó un récord de
importaciones de nl en 2019 por eso
llama mucho la atención que alemania su
mayor consumidor de gas aún no haya
apostado por este tipo de energía y lo
que resulta aún más llamativo si vale
tiene un par de proyectos en marcha pero
su plan principal pasa por un nuevo
gasoducto con rusia el nord stream 2 y
amigos tanto eeuu como los que mandan en
bruselas se han opuesto firmemente este
proyecto porque pues porque no quieren
aumentar la dependencia energética
europea con el kremlin
ahora bien atentos a este gráfico
como veis hasta que llegó el coronavirus
teníamos en europa un mercado en
expansión y si según muestra la barra
azul celeste el gen el estadounidense
había irrumpido con fuerza pero como
podéis ver con el segmento morado rusia
no está dispuesta a ceder fácilmente
cuota de mercado novatech es la empresa
rusa que más está apostando por el gml
así que putin se ha dado cuenta de la
competencia que el gml y de otros países
trae a los gasoductos de gazprom y ya ha
puesto en marcha su nueva estrategia si
los europeos que dejé nl tendrán nl
pero va a ser ruso
el gen l de uso tiene una ventaja sobre
el estadounidense su precio porque uno
de los principales elementos que
influyen en el precio del gen l es el
transporte a menor distancia a cubrir
por los buques metaneros menores la
factura las economías europeas necesitan
ser competitivas y en este aspecto el
coste de la energía sigue siendo uno de
los principales factores a tener en
cuenta
así que como veis le va a resultar muy
pero que muy difícil a la europea
renunciar al gas ruso más aún si tenemos
en cuenta noticias como esta flux
innovatec construir en una terminal
alemana de gm l para 2022 yo lo estáis
preguntando pues si esta noticia
significa que alemania recibirá aún más
y más gas ruso pero qué demonios les
pasa a los alemanes con el gas ruso pero
espera un momento porque el gene de ruso
no sólo mira a occidente las rutas hacia
el este también son viables el deshielo
en el ártico y los rompehielos hacen
posible durante más y más días al año la
navegación hacia el océano pacifico una
vez allí el gas ruso tiene acceso al
continente que más apetito tiene de gas
natural en lo que es más importante
donde más billetes están dispuestos a
soltar por esta fuente de energía
[Música]
tokio
amigos hablamos de gn le hablamos
básicamente de asia este continente es
el destino de casi el 70% del gn el que
se comercia en todo el mundo y japonés
desde hace décadas y con mucha
diferencia el mayor importador del
planeta para que os hagáis una idea por
si mismo japón importa mas gn l que toda
la unión europea además su demanda se
aceleró desde el tsunami de 2011 que
provocó la catástrofe de fukushima y el
apagón nuclear claro que las cosas han
cambiado un poquito desde el año 2014 el
consumo de gas en el país nipón no solo
no ha crecido sino que ha caído un 13%
porque ha bajado la demanda pues porque
varias centrales nucleares volvieron a
ponerse en marcha y porque japón afronta
dos problemas bastante relacionados el
primero el estancamiento de su economía
y el segundo el envejecimiento imparable
de su población en cualquier caso aunque
el interés nipón por el gml se ha
reducido los barcos metaneros han
seguido navegando a todo trapo por el
pacífico seguro que con este gráfico
entendéis por qué
[Música]
en este gráfico podéis ver los efectos
de la oferta y la demanda en todo su
esplendor precios más elevados para ser
representados por las líneas amarilla y
naranja demanda elevada producción
limitada y oferta reducida como podéis
ver hay mucha diferencia entre estas
líneas asiáticas y la roja que
representa al índice henry hub que marca
el precio del gas en eeuu desde la
revolución del fracking la línea roja no
ha parado de descender
bien como hemos dicho la demanda
japonesa se ha reducido desde 2014 sin
embargo a pesar de ello en ese mismo
periodo de tiempo el comercio
internacional de gl ha crecido un 45 por
ciento y las importaciones de asia lo
han hecho en un 36 por ciento y quien
está empujando por tanto la demanda
asiática pues el que todos estáis
pensando mirad las provisiones de wood
mackenzie china superará a japón como
principal importador de genere para 2022
lo cierto es que esta previsión podría
adelantarse y si en realidad este mismo
año debido a las consecuencias
económicas del coronavirus
en cualquier caso de lo que no hay
ninguna duda es de que el despertar del
gigante asiático ha provocado que china
se haya convertido en un devorador de
gas natural en 10 años ha triplicado su
consumo y ojo porque a nivel de gn él ha
multiplicado por 10 sus importaciones
por cierto menudo negociazo ha hecho con
todo esto de australia que suministra ni
más ni menos que en la mitad de todo el
gml que importa china pero no nos
desviemos amigos aquí lo más interesante
es que las importaciones chinas de nl
aún no han tocado techo en los últimos
cinco años venían creciendo a un 30 por
ciento anual hasta el impacto del
coronavirus así que con estos números
está claro china es el mercado clave que
más gas natural liquado demandará en los
próximos años y aquí surge una nueva
cuestión hay alguien que debería dejar
atrás sus ganas comerciales y quiere
evitar los aranceles del 25 por ciento
sobre su gml mira qué ocurrió cuando
beijing otorgó exenciones arancelarias a
varios importadores chinos el 7 de abril
del 2020
eeuu reinicia sus exportaciones de
haendel a china después de un parón de
un año amigos
el acuerdo comercial de la llamada fase
1 comprometió a china a comprar
productos energéticos de eeuu por valor
de más de 50 mil millones de dólares sin
embargo aún mantiene los aranceles para
el gn el estadounidense lo que hace que
las importaciones chinas dependan de
exenciones como las que acabamos de
señalar os así que si transfiere que
eeuu se convierta en esa gran potencia
energética exportadora de gas natural
licuado sabe perfectamente que sus
empresas no pueden perderse el mayor
mercado del mundo estará dispuesto trump
a dar marcha atrás a su guerra comercial
bueno ahí lo dejamos amigos si este
vídeo se ha resultado interesante darle
al botón de like y no olvidéis
suscribiros a visual polític si aún no
lo habéis hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]